la présidence russe a fait savoir que
vladimir poutine et 4 contacts de kobe
de 19 le président est placé en
quarantaine mais ses proches notamment
le porte parole du kremlin dimitri
peskov assure que le chef d'état est en
bonne santé pour en parler on retrouve
notre correspondante à moscou verhaeghe
hoffman
bonjour vera est ce que vous avez plus
de détails sur la santé du président
russe
bonjour e-mailing et vladimir poutine
doit s'isoler pour une période
indéterminée à raison de plusieurs cas
confirmés de covile 19 dans son
entourage c'est le président russe qui
l'a annoncé en personne au cours d'une
conversation téléphonique avec son
homologue tadjik emomali rakhmon off
c'est autorisé le mans va contraindre le
chef d'état russe à ne pas participer en
personne mais en visioconférence au
prochain événement prévu à son agenda
dont le sommet de l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai je vous propose
d'écouter
vladimir poutine a déclaré qu'en raison
des cases identifié d'infection au
coronavirus dans son entourage il devait
respecter une période de confinement
pour une période donnée dans ce contexte
le président russe participera à la
session du conseil de sécurité
collective de l'organisation du traité
de sécurité collective est prévue pour
cette semaine à douchanbé à la réunion
du conseil des chefs d'état des pays
membres de l'organisation de coopération
de shanghai et à la réunion conjointe
des chefs d'état des pays membres de
l'ôter ac et de l'eau cs100
visioconférence
selon le porte parole du kremlin dmitri
peskov le président russe est en
parfaite santé l'a passé en test qui
s'est avéré négatif
malgré un lent dit où les rencontres ont
été nombreuses selon dmitri peskov
aucune personne n'a été exposé en
moindre risque je vous propose d'écouter
on sait qui est tombé malade dans
l'entourage du président le confinement
n'affectent pas directement le travail
du président n'aura simplement pas
d'activité en personne pendant un
certain temps mais encore une fois cela
n'affecte pas l'intensité du travail le
président poursuit son travail par
vidéoconférence c'est à dire qu'il n'y a
pas besoin
deux protocoles spéciaux dans ce cas là
rien ne change
la russie récents sont aujourd'hui plus
de 17000 cas confirmés de kobe 19 dont
près de 1600 à moscou même si la courbe
des contaminations est en baisse le
nombre de décès aussi depuis plusieurs
mois entre 700 et 800 chaque jour merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
verhaeghe hoffman